verantwortungslos wie er ist
das haben wir jetzt schon erlebt dass
fing an als er sagt ganz einfach die
umweltverschmutzungen das gibt es alles
nichts rassismus gibt es nicht es gibt
natürlich den rassismus seit 62 noch
davor damals kennen wir ja schon dagegen
angekämpft und ich muss sagen dass er
amerika wirklich spaltet was zurzeit ist
ich habe heute noch bilder gekommen auch
vom santa monica und wenn es dort sind
viele menschen die auf den straßen leben
im moment man sieht nur zelte zelte
überall von menschen die obdachlos sind
die 40 passagieren
das hat man erschafft ganz einfach chaos
und das schlimmste ist wirklich wir
können nur beten dass beiden diesmal
gewinnt und das über 100 fast 130 140
150 millionen amerikaner wählen was noch
nie passiert ist in der vergangenheit so
eine große wahlbeteiligung das beiden es
wirklich schafft weil wenn er es nicht
schafft dann haben wir vier jahre weiter
gräben zwischen schwarz und weiß
europa als auch deutschland hat er
gesagt deutschland möchte dass ich
verlieren da können wir uns vorstellen
was auf uns zukommt es wird also dann
ganz ganz schwer mit mit mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren